andrew boards
is that like andrew aborts
because he doesn't seem to be at the
board
let's go what you're waiting for
oh there we go e4
what what are we gonna do we're gonna go
for
the sicilian and now we're gonna go a6
knight c3 a bit of a funky way
to try and get a
a um just a night of sicily
and in case my opponent goes for
something like the grand prix then i
have some
different options like the one i chose
that is very interesting the move order
he's chosen
d4 trying to play a normal
or at this semi-normal
open sicilian now i think my opponent
has to take with the queen
in case of knight takes d4 then b4
happens
i don't like this
i think now although i'm a bit
behind the development i do win a fairly
clean pawn i think
knight a4 bish b4
bishop c4 maybe
but i'll go knight f6 e6 and usually in
the night or if you played d6 which
means that e6 is a lot weaker
i think they're as wide you have a lot
more chances
now yeah now i feel as though
my my development is just too good
and e6 is not weak enough
yeah rookie one we'll just go wish b7
continue developing the pieces and
once i castle i'll be very happy
c3 yeah we'll just castle
takes i'll take
to quote
a very famous chess player
um
[Music]
yeah not a lot to be said here with
finnish development it feels like i'm
upon up with um
with a very good position
[Music]
and every chance of
wrapping the game up fairly soon
um okay i don't really see the
point of knight e2 maybe to go knight g3
but that seems a bit slow
so let me okay sorry
uh let me employ one of my favorite
techniques
attacking my abundance pieces which
uh evidently he did not see so now i can
just gobble up that bishop
i protect e4 and i have very few
problems
maybe the plan was b3 that's just smart
queen c7
36 back i protect e4 and
uh no
no worries
queen d4 yeah
that's possible because there's no
bishop c5 that's
where it's protected twice but we'll
just take the pawn on g2
no worries
a bishop a couple of pawns up and the
safer king
life is good
rookie three that doesn't worry me
three threatening mate that was probably
an unfortunate primo
i made comes yeah that was um
after i won that pawn in the opening
yeah that was tough my opponent was
fighting but he was
clearly a if not
lost then very difficult cause